Something always felt off
since I was little.
Winning, praise, the fear of others,
even when I made a fortune at the academy.
None of it really made me happy.
Now, you owe 300 million yen.
- Do you have a way to pay it?
- Of course not!
Gambling's so damn boring.
Debt doesn't mean a goddamn thing to me.
I see. That lack of fear
is what makes you good at gambling.
I'd prefer people like you
pay with your lives, not money.
But you're not the type men really like.
You may not be appropriate
for a life plan.
I know...
The other side. Have you ever seen
the other side of the moon?
Of course you haven't.
Perhaps you've seen a picture of it.
But I've never seen it for myself.
Everyone's just lying to me.
Maybe there's an alien base there.
You can't totally deny
that ridiculous idea, can you?
What are you--?
I just realized that I've never seen
the back of someone's eye socket.
I'll buy your left eye
for 300 million yen.
What color is the back of an eye?
Where are the nerves? How do they connect?
How does it smell? Is there blood?
I want to know, not from reading it
in a book, but from seeing it myself.
She doesn't see me as human.
We can do the removal operation tomorrow.
You have class. We can do it after school.
You're insane! You're a pervert!
President!
Impressive.
I see. Yes, I've never seen anyone
tear their own eye out.
It wasn't that interesting.
Thanks. You can go.
That's not fair!
I... stabbed out my eye!
This was your idea, right?
Take more pleasure in it!